the devil of Hell's Kitchen
is back following on from the defenders
we focus on part-time vigilante Matt
Murdock as he struggled Syst off the
kingpins crime wave there's a lot to
unpack from the show's ending and
throughout this video I'll be discussing
season three in full detail there will
be heavy spoilers and I highly recommend
that you check out the season before
watching this video but without the way
I'm definition and I ruin the show
so you don't have to by the end of
season 3
Wilson Fisk has played New York and the
justice system like pawns on a
chessboard throughout the show he
manipulated the FBI frame daredevil &
exonerated himself in order to get safe
return for his love Vanessa and reclaim
his spot as the kingpin of crime-- the
plan culminates in a wedding but with so
many variables that they eventually go
wrong and things unravel for the super
villain initially Fisk mark tau FBI
agent Raina deem as an easy target
that he could use to remove Vanessa from
being prosecuted Rhea was in over his
head with crippling deaths due to Fisk
cancelling his sister-in-laws
chemotherapy so he was forced to pay for
the costs himself Fisk perfectly
manipulates the character throughout
season 3 and feeds him information so
that he quickly Rises through the ranks
of the FBI this gives him a pawn at the
top by the time daredevil confronts Rey
with the evidence that he is being used
is too late and Rey is in too deep
Nadeem realizes that he must atone for
what he's done after agent Benjamin
Poindexter dressed as daredevil attacks
Clinton Church in an effort to kill
Karen Paige Poindexter is an orphan
sociopath with incredible aim he
appeases Fisk throughout the season by
masquerading as daredevil and framing
him for crime so that the city views him
as a public menace when the Dean begins
working with foggy and math they build a
case against the kingpin but this fails
when the crime Lord threatens the jury
and Rey is put in the
firing line the hit is ordered by
Vanessa and this comes into play in the
final battle similar to how daredevil
revealed the truth to Nadine he does so
with Poindexter daredevil informs him
that Julie in fact didn't break off
contact with him and instead Fisk had
her murdered this drives Poindexter into
a rage and he uncovers Julie's body
before driving it to the FISC wedding to
exact his revenge the Fisk wedding is
ruined and deservedly so
after the theme Stein words are played
across multiple cell phones both
daredevil and Poindexter show up to
exact their revenge the battle between
the three is bloody and brutal and
concludes with Poindexter gang paralyzed
leaving just Matt and Fisk to face off
against each other the showdown between
the two ends in a highly unorthodox
fashion Matt was determined to kill Fisk
when arriving at the hotel however due
to Nadine's dying words he now realizes
that he has enough evidence to send both
the kingpin and Vanessa away for the
rest of their lives even though Fisk
knows Daredevils true identity the two
strike a deal that will keep the secret
safe this will go to jail as long as
Vanessa is safe so he takes the blame
for the crimes Matt agrees to these
terms and the two even shake hands it's
a smart move that allows Matt to not
become a murderer that's also allowing
to keep his secret safe due to the fact
that he could always expose Vanessa if
he was ever compromised Matt foggy and
Karen's celebrate but there's one final
stinger that comes in the form of
Poindexter fans of the comics will of
course come to the realization that the
character Poindexter is bullseye a
mainstay in Daredevils rock gallery this
identity is confirmed when we can see a
bull's-eye reflected in the characters
iris in the show's closing scene it
should be noted that this is a nod to
the comic story in which bullseye was
paralyzed after a battle with daredevil
the character had his bones laced with
adamantium in order to make him
invincible but whether or not this will
happen in the show remains to be seen
but it's a nice Easter Egg for fans of
the villain how the show will proceed at
this point is
but I would definitely like to see
bullseye show up once more though it's
becoming a slight broken record it would
be great to see Elektra resurrected and
then killed by the villain this would
really pick Matt Murdock against
bullseye and I'd love to see the
showdown between the two in the fourth
season so what did you think of
daredevil season 3 how do you think the
storyline will go in season 4 and how
would you rank this one against the
other Netflix Marvel series comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then make sure you check out
my breakdown of the ending of the
Hornung of Hill House which will be
linked at the end of this video this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]